Curiosity is what drives me.
The ultimate thrill to me is diving down to the bottom...
...and finding that fish that nobody has ever seen before.
The key for succeeding is persisting and never giving up.
In life, one should have passion and a feeling of adventure,...
...and that is what my work offers me every day.
I'm really passionate about the mountain environment...
...and the community where I'm living.
I think that is what matters.
I really love my work, and this is why I'm always looking for the next project.
The world's most northerly caves haven't yet been explored.
For me, it's about being limitless.
If there's a horizon, try and see past that horizon.
I get my energy from my people.
They are the ones who are making humanity grow...
...because they are the ones who are protecting us from all the climate impact.
I have the opportunity to do something.
I want to do my part in making a change,...
...providing that basic human right: good nutrition.
That means perseverance, that means integrity and doing it day after day.